I had my time when I punching I had my
time when I my my normal time I'ma flow
all the way through you know what I'm
saying oh just for real like yeah I can
just go all the way through and then
clean it up then I go back down and do
the guy now after I do that [__] I just
let the engineer go try to find a hook
or something between that [__] so you'll
lay down for the most part A one take
all the way through it's a long story so
I don't know how to write a rap and like
read it and wrap it because you'll sound
like you're reading yeah it sounds like
like I can't really like make it it's
not natural it ain't natural and in my
mind to be sending uh [__] that I can't
so you like you don't ever write an idea
down at least I go over the beat I have
the beat sound the beat the beat tell me
what I need to do